and welcome back to the realest podcast
in the Dunya the three Muslims today
we're joined with the three Muslims me
myself and I alhamdulillah we're going
to be reacting to Aiden Ross talking
about the Quran Islam and religion how
do you feel about religion
it's beautiful I when I went to Dubai
like bro Islam like culture in religious
so I immediately want to point out the
fact that as soon as the brother asked
how do you feel about religion Aiden
Ross just right away things about Islam
instantaneously the only religion that
comes to his mind is Islam which I think
speaks volumes for how he feels about
Islam as compared to other religions you
know he's a Jew he's Jewish at least
ethnically and the first thing that
comes to his mind when he's asked about
religion is Islam I think immediately
whether it's conscience or subconscious
Aiden Ross knows that Islam there's
something about it that's special
compared to other religions beautiful
like
people are so true to their religion I
think Islam is beautiful because if
who's Islam in this chat if you're Islam
just put me I don't know listen bro like
if you if you were to offer someone
who's who practices Islam here's 10
million dollars convert now they won't
do it bro like they're really about
they're super genuine and just like
they're truly that's why like I really
respect people who Embrace their that
culture and like when I went to Dubai it
was nothing but love and just you you
feel it from everyone like everyone is
just on some like genuine for real
okay so let's just talk about this for a
second why is this the case why is it
the case that if you go to a practicing
Muslim and you offer them 10 million
dollars to leave the religion they won't
do it and why is it that when you go to
practicing Muslims you find they are
hospitable they have great mannerisms
they will take care of you they will
literally let you into their own home
and take care of you why is this the
case it's because Islam is not just a
religion that comes and it's like oh
yeah this is a True Religion this is a
way of life common practice and blah
blah blah blah and that's it Islam is
something that is self-evident the Quran
is something that is self-evident you
don't read the Quran and learn about it
and think well this is just another book
that's not the case yeah you can skim
through it and throw it aside and out of
ignorance say it's just another book but
when you read the Quran you reflect on
it you look into it you you look at its
claims and you look at the facts
surrounding the Quran like for example
the fact that the Quran is the most
memorized book on the face of the Earth
and when I say most I don't mean like
one million and one people memorize the
Quran and then one million other people
memorize a different book I mean it's
astronomically unique there is no book
even close to the Quran in terms of it
being memorized at least religious book
or book of that size
you know 6 000 words or so so
immediately just hearing about the Quran
knowing that old people kids and
everyone in between you know there's a
huge population of people in the world
who have memorized the Quran is already
I would even say miraculous for human
beings but obviously that's the wrong
word to use in this context so uh
Superior
and as Muhammad a job says you know
noteworthy at least
but what else is there
what else is there there's things like
Prophecy in the Quran and made by the
prophet Muhammad peace be upon Him
things that are so clear for example
very recently the prophet peace be upon
him he said that the hour will not come
the day of judgment basically will not
start will not come until the you know
the deserts of Saudi Arabia Medina these
places return
to being you know Gardens and medals
like Greenery
and you think that it's a it's a desert
how is it going to do that it literally
just happened it literally just happened
and go look to the extent of the green
here it's beautiful subhanallah go look
it up and this and look up the Hadith as
well this is the narration of the
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon Him 1400
years ago and this is just one small
example he has many other prophecies
many other miracles of the Quran and not
one book
has been compared to the Quran in any
way
and anyway there's not a book on the
face of the earth that could be compared
to the Linguistics of the Quran the um
like I mentioned the people who
memorized the Quran the uh scientific uh
what people like to call Miracles even
the style of the Quran the linguistic
elements of the Quran especially in the
Arabic language and there's nothing
that's comparable to it they talk about
the whole ring composition and all that
and the Quran makes a challenge says
bring one person one person or one group
of people just make one chapter like the
Quran bring anyone to make just one
chapter similar to the Quran in 1400
years no one has been able to do it why
is that because the Quran is unique so
that's why when you go to Muslims they
they will not give up Islam for anything
they know Islam is worth more than a
million dollars your million dollars is
nothing especially nowadays by the way
10 million dollars is nothing
compared to Islam compared to an
eternity of reward and Bliss from the
one who created us
what is what is
you know compared to 10 million dollars
what is 10 million dollars compared to
Islam
nothing
so that's why Muslims are so strong in
their faith and obviously Islam teaches
us to be good too you know both Muslims
and non-muslims to be generous to be
kind to have good character to take care
of those to be hospitable and so on and
so forth
by religion is beautiful bro
but I think if you're super religious
and
um like bro I'm Jewish and the Quran is
like there's a lot of Truth to the Quran
bro like a lot of stuff that I really
like like stand by like the Quran is
beautiful and I haven't really studied
the Holy Bible like that but the Quran
itself is just amazing bro like that's
why you could really I put I I don't
know do you do you think
so I don't I don't know nothing about
the Quran so educate me it's a Quran
like okay can I be honest a lot of a lot
of the stuff the Quran has uh applies to
today like a lot a lot bro
that's I watch videos on it and um I
read up on stuff and people discuss it
and break it down because I don't really
understand absolutely
absolutely see he gets it see Aiden Ross
actually understands it you read the
Quran and you see that everything that's
in it still applies to today why because
the Quran is timeless the Quran is a
book that if you live in 1400 uh if you
live in in 600 A.D if you live 1400
years ago in Arabia it applies then and
the prophet Muhammad peace be upon Him
built established and and maintained an
entire Society an entire nation based on
the Quran and this by the way is the
same Nation the same nation that beat
the Romans whatever was left of the
Persians they'll conquered basically
everything up to the borders of China
and and down to the the bottom of Africa
Islam spread like that in a few decades
based on the Quran based on the the
religion of Islam based on what the
prophet Muhammad peace and blessings be
upon Him brought to us through or from
Allah and the reason Aiden I want to
talk to you directly the reason you read
the Quran and you say wow you know this
is tremendous and you get that feeling
that you know you can't really get this
from another book it's because the Quran
is the word from Allah he who knows you
better than God who knows you and me as
as individuals better than God the human
being in general who knows that that
that biological creature more than God
nobody so Allah knows exactly God knows
exactly what gets you ticking what makes
you move what makes you stagnant what
benefits you and what harms you
actually better much better than our own
selves that's why Allah says in the
Quran there may be something that is bad
for you although you love it and there
being be something that is good for you
although you hate it you don't know and
Allah knows this is the superiority of
the Quran compared to other books and
other ways of life and how else does
Islam apply today let's look at
something very simple Allah he talks
about the corruption that will manifest
in the land and the sea from the hands
of what human beings do
and and I don't think there's a time
where this applies more than to today
where not only do you have you know
corruption with Bloodshed and murder and
and all these things of innocent human
beings around the world also with
animals and communities animal societies
animal species have gone extinct because
of human beings on their hands and what
they do
also look at how we're polluting the
earth look at how we're polluting the
ocean look at how we're destroying
animal life we're destroying Forest
we're destroying natural reserves we're
just as human beings as a nation we're
destroying a lot
and then because of what we've done we
see the effect it has in the world the
effect it has on the animals the effect
it has in the ocean the effect it has on
us eventually it comes back and hits us
eventually
all because of what our hands have done
that's still how the Quran applies today
that's something that's still very
relevant to today
things like legislation and I want you
to know
a lot of the things we have in society
today like for example the notion of
innocent till proven guilty that came
from the Muslims that came from Islam
that came from the Quran
even the even the basis even the basis
of if you want to make a claim bring
bring your proof and evidence it's found
in the Quran 1400 years ago and this is
the basis that people who like IBN Cena
some he identified as a Muslim although
he had some beliefs that took him out of
the fold of Islam they've been saying he
used things like that to you know really
solidify the the scientific method back
then
and then you also had other people like
uh who created Optics and some say even
other inventions that the Muslims had at
the time they created math and algebra
and all these things because after
receiving the Quran they realized that
Allah created the world and a a kind of
fixed way
a kind of a solid way in a particular
way where you can actually measure so
you can measure certain laws you can
measure certain realities you could do
tests and you can you know really use
these things create inventions and
understand how the world works
for example Allah says in the Quran have
you seen the she camel and how she how
she was constructed
because the chemicals back then were
like cars for them they were made
literally for Desert travel
so Allah says have you seen that she
came on how she was constructed you know
things like that really makes a person
want to investigate biology animals life
even things like physics gravity and
there are even some some people that say
that Newton's understanding of gravity
actually came from the Muslims a fourth
time ago
obviously new one's understanding was
wrong
but still regardless Muslims were
already kind of on this you know a
thousand years ago
so yeah at the end of the day when you
look at Islam in the Quran as opposed to
other ways of life other religions
you find it's really no competition
there is really no competition
and you look at society and the problems
they have degeneracy disrespecting the
parents men not being men every single
problem that you can find in society
today whether it's with capitalism alert
or liberalism or whatever other ISM
there is feminism or whatever Islam
fixes it Islam is a solution to it and I
don't mean Islam says do this and that
and you'll fix it I mean Islam as a full
system will not even allow such a thing
to exist
because Islam is preventative it doesn't
come and give you a pill to give you a
cure it prevents the whole issue from
arising to begin with because of the
beautiful system of Islam and with that
being said obviously we invite brother
Aiden Ross and brother zias and and
anyone else who wants to discuss Islamic
religion onto the show to discuss with
us
foreign